hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mad
father okay we're wandering through this
and one of you was kind enough to tell
me what I needed to do which was pretty
obvious to begin with but I don't know
why I didn't do it
so I'm an idiot oh yeah that's why I'm
totally dumb okay so anyway we're
carrying through onto here and here's
the headless head just squish step right
over but what needs to happen is I need
to push the baby into her into her arms
so that they'd be happy a mother and her
baby sleeping close because I was part
of this story and one of you also
informed me that I missed a gem whoops
oh well you guys um probably expected me
to much of me if you expected me to get
all the gems
I killed an animal for fun then I got
addicted there's always dead cats and
birds in my room mother gets mad when
she finds him whenever her mother is out
I had the corpses in the dresser so I
need to put the corpses of the birdies
in the dresser a dead bird oh ah I
picked it up oh no mother I hope you
don't find the bloodstains all over the
bed that's not good
did kitty oh that's so sad
alright hide him in there good story
good now are we good the boy looks bored
she's gonna kill another something oh
whoops
uh wait a minute I don't crap I don't
think I'm supposed to do that first
nutters damn it
okay now I need to come on everybody
Boosh oh no I'm the mother
what is his blood stain son I'm not too
happy with the situation here Zach
enough let's see
I think it's mad when she finds him
whenever mother is out of hide what what
am I gonna do
corpses in the dresser an old dresser
whoa where am I supposed to put her if
this is father-to-be obvious it's not
very obvious for me
okay so epic puzzle solving skills where
would the mother need to be in order to
be cool Douglas lady lady seriously
how about you just stand in the corner
lady oh when the mother is out oh maybe
the mother needs to go away I think
that's what needs to happen okay trying
to pay just bear with me everybody I'm
I'm terribly stupid yeah oh honey thank
you about time
kid you okay you're gonna kill some more
animals that's how Dexter got started
whoa-ha-ha daint good mother found out I
was killing animals mother scolded me
shut up
I stabbed mother with a knife mother
fell over all red it didn't suit such a
pretty face so I wiped mother's face her
dead face was very pretty
okay
oh no the boy is covered with blood
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
use the kitchen knife his napkin oh
that's why I had the napkin squeaky
squeaky all clean is very dot dot dot
boy's covered with blood
okay her dead face is very pretty she
stabbed mother with a knife fell over
all red what else needs to be done here
Oh tell me I don't need to stab her no
remember mm mm mm mm run run run up to
buck rum rum rum okay
okay no no mini chainsaws up the butt
okay so what am i needing to do here see
and aunt burnt burnt okay stab mother
with a knife didn't suit it a pretty
face await her face is very dot dot dot
so I need to make her face pretty well
how do I do that do I let me pick up
this deadhead and smash it on to hers
maybe I need to Bhushan closer covered
in blood what what the hell oh maybe I
need to give the kid the knife oh I
might not have been a good idea ah I'm
getting wood what is that I killed
mother Oh scared and ran away far far
away toward the ocean I wanted to forget
everything but I couldn't forget
mother's dead pretty Dead face Oedipus
complex I killed another eventually got
addicted to seeing people's dead faces
right dead blade oil wields a pickaxe
looking down that girl did terribly
frightened okay so what I need to push
this guy closer so he's gonna kill her
what is it oh oh oh that I don't want to
do that I mean to do that let me do that
admit it and me to do that I'm sorry
no more vroom vrooming I didn't expect
that to happen okay
claps I can't move my legs
I have to save father fat her collapse
well you must be exhausted
oh hello mr. Victor whatever your crap
your neighbors at your limit are you
perhaps you wish I dressed up edge it
scoop don't take me all the way back if
you take me all the way back to my bed I
would be able to find gem cuz I know
where it is and then I'm gonna stab all
the barrels in the faces come here aya
hug huggles hug everybody
mom you're warm hug hug it'd be bad if
she was cold close your eyes I up what
are you gonna do to me why
may you be smiled upon or did she plan a
kiss on my forehead mom what was that a
good-luck charm a what charm a charm you
so you'll always always be happy from
now on ma Wow I love you mom
oh this is adorable not in so adorable
because I would happens later on but
it's adorable now mom you smell nice no
that's the red eyed guy
the perfume mom always used hi-hi indeed
you smell like mom why do you smell like
mom oh hi
God mom give it back
that's my mom's No come back here drown
it okay so I'm in a room why is this the
the nurses room by the way I saw all of
the fan art with the shut up nurse make
out with me Oh doc they were all very
good I loved everyone's individual take
on it Rob wrap up okay I shouldn't Brum
Brum but it's just too addicting
I just want a room room everyone I'm
gonna brumberg come here lady
rah rah rah
I can't go back row ma'am rim
okay what's in here it's locked so what
was with the dog did I see anything with
the dumb ass oh it's a stuffed dog I
don't know I didn't read that the first
time and see here straight room was that
mean hang on I'm gonna go save cuz I
have a feeling that I'm gonna deviate
the bath in the straight o case there I
thought it wasn't there okay
oh whoops I just saved over my old tape
well darn it
there goes my backup okay nevermind then
let's see straight room facing in here
lots of bats a gem a gorge
ooh I go every night no no no oh god I
I'm from from you a camera I'm ah I got
murdered to death by bats padded why
would I pick the bat and that's why I
saved cuz I know bad things were gonna
happen so what about what do I do
ah go back go back go back come on go
back I'm not gonna back oh not gonna
make yeah not gonna make it
yeah I almost made it if I hadn't I
almost made it I'm gonna make it just
give me a grin dang dong damn second
guys
how do i I don't know how to I can't
broom broom them so what do I do
pick it up let's go let's go come on you
gonna make it you're gonna make it you
gonna make it leaving yourself Nick it
little there we go alright outright
outright made it good we're awesome
super awesome we're more than awesome or
double extra ultra awesome okay so now
that we've made it thoroughly now I can
sprint forward yeah my way nope nope got
it
I'm gonna marry cuz I bye she's wrong
for you
I'm not gonna make it oh how the play
alibi
ah Oh dorky
it's to the door that's locked I'm so
dumb I'm so stupid
terribly sometimes it hi
uh no good ma'am
you're gonna eat that you can eat that
mouse that'd be me
guess this sense no good animals seem to
hate it well give it back cuz I need
that your letter of room from you right
up to a board from Lulu up to bots and
it's not gonna feel good huh you don't
have it where did you put it
I don't know look around hi come back
here
Shh kid found a photo says stuffed dog
with a bone into its mouth do I have to
put a bone in the room mmm-hmm ah
Squiggy come here where'd you go hi puts
the shot away I see some back there
drum ride hello rum-rum-rum
okay I like this chainsaw mom's perfume
how did it get back there ah alright I
got a part of her Rob maybe I just need
to carry it with me Jeong Jeong Jeong
did it calm down probably not okay but
I'm on perfume just a little bit okay
mom okay mama whatever you Theodore
linger
you're the light of my life i doused
myself in perfume doused just a little
bit mom
oh no I just realized someone's gonna
take a gif of my webcam of me going
sploosh and I just not gonna be good I
just realized what I did there hang on
there's blood on the wall messaging
blood on the wall you said I'd be family
line who said that
I did I say that's he rhymes I'm doused
in my mother's perfume you know why for
me you hate me I rocks cool
what are you doing here no no no no nope
ah no way oh look at Evan no are you
whoa whoa whoa no nope ha ha No ah nice
doing it getting a tear how do I get out
how do I get out okay nope I think
that's enough for now okay so I'm done
with that I'm done house okay so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos soon I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
ah
seems like the stairway
this is like those guys
point seven
I'm gonna get me